[Music]
today for the final time we cancelled
the mask nazis or perhaps in fact not
for the final time um after the hero
judge in florida ruled that the cdc's
mask mandate was unlawful
i said on this show yesterday that the
administration would complain about the
ruling but they wouldn't challenge it
after we've all seen the videos you know
of air passengers cheering over the news
of the mass mandate ending like it was
the fall of the berlin wall
you know challenging the ruling
potentially overturning it would be
politically suicidal especially heading
into midterms
but i may have underestimated this
regime's penchant for doing politically
suicidal things as the daily wire
reports today the buying administration
will appeal a court ruling by a u.s
district judge who ruled monday the
administration's national mass mandate
on public transportation was unlawful
quote the department of justice and the
center for disease control and
prevention disagree with the district
court's decision and will appeal subject
to cdc's conclusion that the order
remains necessary for public health
the department continues to believe that
the order requiring masking in the
transportation corridor is a valid
exercise of the authority congress has
given cdc for to protect public health
this is an important authority the
department will continue to work to
preserve
well this is why you shouldn't listen to
my predictions on this kind of thing it
turns out that i'm still somehow too
optimistic to be a reliable political
prognosticator
now i still suspect that this appeal
will be mostly for show
but maybe not
perhaps the democrats figure they've
already got so many nails in the coffin
that they might as well add one more
heading into the midterms
if they succeed in forcing masks back
onto people's faces it will be
wildly unpopular with normal people but
at least the media will feel good about
it speaking of which here's andy slavitt
on msnbc last night expressing his
disappointment over the judge's ruling
listen
we're seeing today people have to react
to i'm going to get on a plane
in about an hour
thankfully i'm vaccinated and boosted
and have a good quality mask so should
feel she'll feel reasonably good
but you know i think usually we would
like to see the cdc which has the
authority to make these decisions make
this decision
not not a judge
the cdc had asked for 15 more days to
review data i think it's it's important
that we we see that we have to remember
there are cancer patients and
four-year-olds that are not vaccinated
or are vulnerable
uh so hopefully
people will continue to to show good
judgment and protect themselves and
protect others where possible
oh the cdc only asked for 15 days well
okay then
i mean if we've learned anything over
the past two years it's that 15 days is
just 15 days when they say 15 days they
mean it we all know that
that's the great lesson of the pandemic
it's just that you have to keep in mind
that the word day is is relative
now we might think of a day
as 24 hours but that's just from the
perspective of earth on venus for
example a day lasts 5832 hours or about
243 earth days what the cec and our
other public health authorities forgot
to mention is that when they say 15 days
they're referring to venus days not
earth days
simple miscommunication is all i'm glad
andy slavitt could help clear that up
for us
another cable news pundit roland martin
is having an even harder time with the
news this is what he tweeted yesterday
he says i don't give a damn about what
some grossly unqualified donald trump
judge said i'm double masked and wearing
goggles on this nashville to dc flight i
had coveted in december you all can kiss
my ass about me not wanting it again and
any fool saying they don't matter is a
damn liar
you have to love the hat that says
roland martin unfiltered
which is on top of
a head covered in goggles and two masks
some irony overload there
honestly though if i knew that this
fruitcake was flying out of nashville
and his mask and goggles yesterday i
would have gone to the airport and got
on that plane just so i could sit next
to him and cough and sneeze for the
entire flight
for his own good of course
now now look this may seem like just a
bunch of virtue signaling from martin
but it's actually not i mean it's not
merely virtue signaling anyway the fact
is that this man like so many others on
his side of the ideological fence
has been psychologically disfigured by
two years of covert fear-mongering
he's still not scared enough for his
health to you know go on a diet i mean
he's not going to panic that much
but he is legitimately afraid to go
bare-faced on a plane i believe that his
fear and paranoia and effeminate
cowardice are all real
granted there are people on the replies
to his post
you know
to this tweet posting recent pictures of
him at large public events without a
mask and saying that he's like a
hypocrite
but this is all part of the broken brain
syndrome
that is incoherent and arbitrary risk
calculation
that's one of its most prevalent
symptoms
and i think nothing quite captures the
damage done to people by two years of
cobit hysteria
like this short clip taken on a jetblue
flight right after the announcement
about the mask mandate was made
you could see the flight attendants
ripping off their masks and and
literally dancing for joy
and that's all great but listen to what
one of them says it's very interesting
listen
this is the kind of speaking um
right now
all night jeffree we will require we
don't require a mask
oh my gosh
look at my face i don't even know how to
change it
oh my god yay
you can follow them and wave them in the
air like you just don't care
um but please don't throw them on the
floor because you have to clean out you
will be coming here with your sex in
just a moment
so she skips down the aisle uh waving
the mask over her head feeling
justifiably elated and joyful and she
says
look at my face i have a face
now that might seem like a joke but
there's actually something quite
profound in that statement i think
because by far the most terrible and
oppressive thing about masking
was not how uncomfortable it was
or what a ridiculous charade the whole
thing was but rather the fact that the
mask turns you into a faceless automaton
the mask is dehumanizing
and this is especially the case for
workers in the service industry who were
turned into a literal faceless servant
class
forced to muzzle themselves like dogs
and become anonymous
depersoned serfs over the last two years
on planes everybody was in that position
we've heard so much about the epidemic
of violence and fighting on planes over
the last two years and i'm convinced
that this explains why it's not just
that people were annoyed and on edge
about the masks but that when you put
people into a high stress situation
in a confined space with each other
and you cover everybody's faces so they
can't fully see and appreciate and
encounter each other's humanity
you end up with exactly the chaos that
we experienced
people need to see each other
and be seen by each other
this is not a want or a desire or a nice
luxury
but an actual human need
because we are all human beings after
all
we were born with faces and with the
natural inclination to connect with
other humans primarily through facial
cues
the first thing a newborn baby does is
look at and study his mother's face and
it's quite amazing to behold as i've
seen
four times
that a baby comes out of the womb
already
knowing kind of where to look
baby doesn't know anything else but he
will look at your face
we are literally born with this instinct
this ability this need to see and
recognize faces
remove that from people for a prolonged
period of time and you're depriving them
of something that is so
essentially human in a deep and primal
sort of way
the writer jonathan franzen wrote an
essay back in the 90s complaining about
the very new trend at the time of people
walking down the street talking on their
cell phones
and uh he didn't like it very much and
he said quote all i really want from a
sidewalk is that people see me
and let themselves be seen
now perhaps because of our cell phone
addictions we had got accustomed to not
seeing and being seen by other people
even when we're standing two feet from
them and so the masking for some wasn't
much of a stretch
they weren't losing anything that they
hadn't already effectively lost
but that just means that if the masks
didn't bother you
it's only because you'd already
despaired of your humanity
so the people that brag about it didn't
bother me much
that's because you're sick you're a sick
person psychologically and emotionally
and spiritually
if it didn't bother you it should bother
you
it should bother you to not have your
face scene or be able to see other
people's faces
if it doesn't it's because you'd already
given up on some of the most crucial
aspects of being human
there's a reason why leftists in
particular are so comfortable in masks
it's because their ideology puts them at
war with human nature at every turn in
every way
they deny everything that's natural and
good and healthy
they want to take everything that is
true and human away from us
they even want to take away our faces
as i watched some of these videos of
people celebrating
the perhaps temporary unfortunately end
of mask tyranny i thought about another
writer c.s lewis
who wrote a book called till we have
faces um now the title refers to faces
in a spiritual sense but that's partly
because c.s lewis prophetic as he was
never imagined that he would we we would
live in a world where our actual faces
are taken away
at the very end of that book lewis
writes this
he says i saw well while the gods do not
speak to us openly nor let us answer
until that word can be dug out of us why
should they hear the babble that we
think we mean
how can they meet us face to face till
we have faces
now this is obviously meant to be
understood in a very spiritual and
poetic sort of way referring to the true
self-knowledge that comes from
surrendering oneself to god
but in modern times
till we have faces takes on a
frighteningly literal meaning
to take off the mask is to have a face
an identity it is to in many ways
reclaim your humanity
and that only sounds like an
exaggeration to people who have already
given up on theirs
and in the end
is those people who are canceled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content